régine
tata est formidable je les ai vus comme
ça deux fois avec jane fonda et vous
c'est toi qui avait passé une semaine de
110 ans après elle a mille appartements
à mon nom alors votre dernière
apparition médiatique régine c'était la
ferme célébrités et vous raconter dans
le livre qui vous amène ce soir que
quand pierre palmade notre ami pierre
palmade a appris que vous participiez à
la ferme célébrités il a dit je ne serai
plus jamais la parole il m'a dit qu'est
ce que c'est que qu'est-ce que je viens
d'apprendre qu'est ce que c'est que
cette merde que tu vas faire là tout
simplement
voilà tu dit écoute avant de m'insulter
et de dire que vient il faut que tu
expliques n'en vient pas il a fallu que
je supplie il est venu et ça a duré
toute la nuit
voilà et ça s'est arrangé et au final
vous n'êtes pas mécontente régime
d'avoir participé à cette mascarade
paysanne
d'abord ça vous a permis d'entrer dans
de nombreux foyers s'il est de gommer un
peu votre votre image de reine de la
nuit ça c'est important
ensuite j'ai quand même rapporter 80
mille euros à l'association sos habitat
et soins
vous avez retrouvé quelque chose de
votre enfance à la campagne
vous avez perdu 8 kg je n'ai pas besoin
de mes kilos et surtout on peut dire que
ça vous a permis de renouer le dialogue
avec l'homme le plus important de votre
vie c'est l'affairé lionel de vous voir
dans la ferme célébrités ils m'ont
envoyé des lettres à c marrant ouais
faut dire la vérité et je dois dire sans
beaucoup soutenu et surtout matiti ouais
alors lionel c'est lionel road cage
c'est votre votre fils le fils de paul
roquecave votre premier mari avec qui
j'ai été mariée à l'âge de 16 ans
divorcée à 19
vous dites le quotidien d'une mère au
foyer s'était pas fait pour moi c'était
pas très pour moi mais c'est vrai que
maintenant je me pose la question quand
on est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
tard et qu'on est
moi j'adore les enfants et je suis très
amer poublan maintenant et c'est vrai
que par moments ça me manque
l époque en tous les cas ça n'allait pas
du tout avec ce pôle rhd ketch parce que
vous vous aimiez sortir lui pas du tout
il ya le fameux épisode du boeuf sur le
toit ou qu'ils allaient un jour et vous
êtes à 6 très très très haut très loin
des stars vous regardez en bas vous
voyez toutes ses vedettes et permis de
voir les 5
de la femme doris ahnen superbe et
qu'elle montrait généreusement
c'est vrai que le côté vip étaient déjà
dans ma tête et la sibérie je savais où
c'était c'était là haut et j'étais
furieux je pensais qu'il n'avait pas
donné un pourboire assez important voilà
alors pour pouvoir divorcer de paul
rutledge vous vous êtes fait prendre en
flagrant délit d'adultère
voilà alors cette anecdote comme
beaucoup d'autres sont dans votre
nouveau livre régine qui s'appelle moi
mes histoires c'est aux éditions du
rocher
mais dites moi
elles remplacent ceux qui se garent dans
mame
-
amour
amitié
et j'irai
alors la régie moi mes histoires aux
éditions du rocher
son nouveau livre de souvenirs alors
vous raconter aussi c'est assez tragique
votre premier amour claude heymann là
vous aviez 13 ans luis saez et il a été
ramassé par les allemands quand il
allait la synagogue parlé avec le rabat
de sa relation avec vous il a été
déporté par le dernier train le 11 août
44 il n'est jamais revenu quoi est
toujours là ouais ça vous a marqué
définitivement ça oui je crois que ça a
été mon premier amour et mon seul grand
amour indre pardon pour tous mais oui
mais aix oui abbas khan a eu après ils
sont pas mal et ça commence avec le
tournage du jour le plus long à la voûte
ap carrément tout le casting un régime
faut bien le dire
robert mitchum oui ça c'était déjà avant
voilà warren beatty c'était avant c'est
vrai qu'il a un sexe énorme arabité et
bomal non parce que c'est la réputation
fort à bourvil il est pas mal et
pourtant warren beatty l'été avec
natalie wood à l'époque quand même non
oui je les abats imaginer ça c'est à
dire que il est ensemble sans être
ensemble et il me tenait la main dans
son dos et lui a donné une paire de
gifles à les cordages ce qui nous a
rapprochés tous les deux d'ailleurs pas
fait alors il ya eu jane kelly aussi ce
qui est extraordinaire parce que j'étais
petit j'allais le voir au cinéma vous
lago riez et un jour voulait taper
bailly superbe était superbe il était
super mais pour moi il reste superbe en
plus un homme extrêmement délicat
charmant et puis à danser à danser ma
passion et et c'est vrai que c'est
c'est merveilleux est ce que est ce
qu'on peut faire l'amour avec quelqu'un
duty on rêve
oui oui doré bambi étant gosse jamais
baisé aveugle
c'est un long terme qu'à une chance y'a
bon bees 2 qui sort la haye à steve
mcqueen aussi lorsqu'on apprend en
lisant votre bouquin c'est que vous
parliez pas anglais et quand sans vous
parliez une vie douce parce qu'il avait
travaillé dans une épicerie juive
lorsqu'isabelle 1
il connaissait l'essentiel de ce qu'il
fallait dire et poserait il ya un truc
énorme énorme
vous êtes tapé jean claude killy c'est
un souvenir plus que charmant plus que
formidable et partez le lendemain pour
les états unis et il est devenu l'homme
qu'il est est un homme extraordinaire et
que je respecte énormément
ah bah nous aussi donc c'était sa
timidité que vous trouviez
l'irrésistible un jean claude killy
c'est la genèse charme champion moi
jamais champions d'accord c'est un bon
coup jean claude killy nous permettrait
de ne pas répondre
il était très bien alors il ya aussi el
cordobès le célèbre matador alors la
personne vous a vu pendant trois jours
après votre rencontre n'entre qu'à vingt
dix les organiser dans chez castel qui
était ma boîte concurrentes
j'organise un autre dîner au sujet
castel et j'ai kidnappé cordobès parce
que je veux danser le twist à ce moment
là et que cet un ancien formidable et
très drôle et très intelligent et ne il
n'écrivait pas ne savait pas écrire et
son par l'espagnol était tellement
rapide que même pas un espagnol c'était
difficile de le comprendre mais je
l'avais vu à nîmes se mettre à genoux
devant le taureau embrasser le taureau
c'est à moi maintenant c'est new york a
duré longtemps avec el cordobès je vous
demande en mariage
vraiment
avec cheikh pour me dédommager si
j'abandonnais la nuit un bon coup elle
cordobès régime très très bien très très
bien je vois dans votre gare souvenirs
sur quelque chose qui chaviré alors
d'argent latine lover évidemment vous
avez été là la maîtresse du playboy
porfirio rubirosa joueur de polo grand
joueur de polo
vous savez qu'on surnomme les poivrier
robbie rose à cause de la taille de son
sexe résine écoutez on parlera pas de
ceux de ce détail parce que pour moi ça
avec un détail me restait on est
respecté la chance pour délester
on est resté longtemps encore jusqu'où
tu le soir où il a trouvé la mort
malheureusement après avoir gagné le
match de polo il avait 60 ans il m'a
regardé il m'a dit je pense que je suis
trop vieux c'est vrai qu'à l'époque 60
ans était alors que des hommes pensaient
qu'ils étaient trop vieux alors que
maintenant à 60 enfin c'est le début de
la jeunesse bien sûr il y en a avec qui
ça s'est pas très bien passé quand même
c'est omar sharif à cause du chien
aliapur déchire vous avez perdu un seul
appât nom rime beaucoup on aurait
vraiment beaucoup
chaque fois je suis resté ami avec tout
mes amants et c'est très rare il ya un
scoop énorme rond dans son bocal
compliqué je sais pas où on va falloir
claude françois écouter claude françois
je vois pas claude françois en 3d
mais il était comme ça quand on va en
soit aussi
non je trans'oise une histoire très
amusant je le connaissais d'avant
puisque on dansait beaucoup ensemble
c'est un danseur remarquable on le sait
on l'a vu et on faisait des tas de
figure ensemble et on avait déjà eu une
aventure ensemble
donc ce n'était pas quelque chose de
nouveau ça s'est poursuivi simplement à
saint tropez d'une façon très et je lui
ai dit tu dois chanter seule voie là et
je lui ai trouvé sa chanson belles
belles toiles a alors voulu d'une
relation courte mais dense
vous entendez quoi par balles c'est
resté huit jours au lean parce que d un
d'accord alors il ya eu aussi maurice
herzog qui revenaient de la nature mais
vous savez bien les champions 1
j'aime bien les hommes qui ont du
charisme ouais et qu'on les gérer c'est
dommage qu'on était fâché si longtemps
forêt est mieux compris ouais quand tu
vois qu'il ya eu jane borg
ben pas mal et je nie pas prêt à jouer
au tennis
moi mon côté ça ressemblait à un champ
de jong il avec elle les balaie le passé
avec l agile avec l âge il avait 23 ans
carlos monzon
oui je sais la moitié environ des
champions un peu henri leconte
non non on a fait la même ni champions
mais quelle quel charmant garçon jacques
brel et jacques brel pas beaucoup de
femmes dans votre vie sexuelle jean sauf
une françoise sagan vous aviez 24 ans
elle avait 18 ans et vous dit en parlant
d'elle si seulement j'avais pu être
lesbienne
oui oui parce que je l étais très
attractive elle était et que moi j'étais
très être au grade sûrement par pas
éduqué du tout j'ai vécu comme un trois
ans dans un couvent et c'était mais non
je veux dire que je pense qu'avec la vie
que j'ai mené ce high tone beaucoup les
gens pensaient qu'on était ensemble on
n'a jamais démenti
et ça n'était pas le cas et je me dis
que peut-être dû manquer quelque chose
parce que je suis au mans je l'adoré
sûrement alors votre deuxième mari roger
choc on était très très jaloux de
françoise sagan puis il était très
jaloux parce que je lui avais promis
juste avant qu'on se marie que je
rentrerai plutôt ça voulait dire l'heure
où commence vraiment à s'amuser c'est à
dire 4 heures du matin 4 heures du matin
je suis jamais rentrée dont françoise me
faisais des petits beau mon cher aux
jets et régine n'a pas pu rentrer
j'avais perdu mes clients elle a passé
deux heures et demie aller chercher on
les a pas trouvés alors elle m'attire
pas guy voilà vous êtes séparés
récemment de votre marraine et sa main
et dans les termes les plus
mais plus courtois puis surtout avec
beaucoup de tendresse d'amour
ouais nous respectons beaucoup et je les
aime beaucoup il m'aime beaucoup
ça n'empêche pas de faire l'amour j'ai
gardé de mes amants j'en ai gardé que
deux surtout ce nom de rouler sur la
langue
au régime effectivement 75 ans deux
amants vous dites je fais toujours
l'amour et quand je le fais je le fais
mieux qu'avant bien sûr ice est plus
tentant mais vous dites je suis pâmé
salines qui attend les hommes sur le
divan g que deux boyfriend comme tout le
monde à peu près comme tout le monde
vous préférez l'amour l'après midi
plutôt l'après midi
qu est ce que vous dites le soir avant
de me coucher j'ai tout un rituel
le démaquillage la vaisselle le
téléphone les temps donc le temps que
vous avez fait tout ça le mec est
endormi et bien sûr d'où l'après midi et
l'après midi j'avais beaucoup de temps
musique je suis pas très câline je passe
pas des heures a roulé boulé sous la
couette ça m'ennuie quoi c'est vrai un
peu plus câline maintenant ouais
le sexe n'est pas primordial pour vous
en faites pas du tout non c'est d'abord
ma tête j'ai reçu que votre mari
comprenait pas pourquoi vous aviez une
réputation de coquines parce que lui en
fait
roger il trouvait pas vous étiez un
super coup c'est ça peut-être bah oui
enfin il tient quand même à moi et moi
lui ferais ça quand même marché 34 ans
mais une série que vous connaissez bien
les hommes vous dites je suis une geisha
je m'occupe très bien des hommes écoutez
je m'occupe de jilib dans leur bain ah
oui
ah oui
les histoires publiées jeudi
ce pas de temps
dans l'autre
didier et
les bruits catherine 1
un vieux papier chiffon puis si un soir
j'ai vu voir
vous consoler que
c
il est en papier par qui
audard mais nous nous à la sortie vous
l'attendez le
oui
c'est la chute
accorder deux jours
bon de plus
une cambiale marron
do
mais ces bijoux
et plus à minuit là
autour du cou
regardez
oui
j'entends
chanteront
oui le point
par jour
et free
elle compte
avec des sanglots longs et les yeux de
la main droite en mieux
comme je veux
passionné s'agit là
je ne sais pas
l'état
m
régine